we are just hours away from a scheduled
vote in the House Judiciary Committee on
whether to hold Attorney General William
Barr in contempt over his refusal to
release an unredacted version of the
Mullah report and other evidence
including grand jury material meanwhile
there seems to be at least a rhetorical
split between Barr and his FBI director
over well they whether the government
spied on the Trump presidential campaign
chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge shows us tonight
thank you for your presence here during
a routine budget hearing a Senate
Democrat asked a wide-ranging question
about FBI tactics with the director of
voting the same spying language as his
boss the Attorney General that's not the
term I would use I would say that's a no
I believe that the FBI is engaged in
investigative activity and part of
investigative activity includes
surveillance activity last month Barr
said spying occurred on the Trump
campaign questioning whether it was
based on credible intelligence meaning
to political pushback and a media frenzy
last week Barr stood by his choice of
language
I think spying is a good English word
that in fact doesn't have synonyms
because it is the broadest word
incorporating really all forms of covert
intelligence collections during the 2016
campaign the FBI secured a surveillance
warrant for a Trump campaign aide Carter
page which allows for communications
collection well beyond the original
target when press director ray answered
carefully citing the ongoing inspector
general investigation into alleged
surveillance abuse during the 2016
campaign do you have any evidence than
any illegal surveillance into the
campaign's or individuals associated
with the campaigns by the FBI occurred I
don't think I personally have any
evidence of that sort as tensions
between the Justice Department and the
democrat-led House Judiciary Committee
escalate over access to the full Special
Counsel report in underlying records a
senior Democrat shot back after the
Senate majority leader said the Dems
can't let go it's finally over
what we've seen is a meltdown absolutely
melt out Mitch McConnell is aiding and
embedding it by refusing to do anything
it may be the Trump wants the Russians
to part
Cepeda he's telling mcconnell to do
nothing the democrat-led House Judiciary
Committee is poised to vote Wednesday
morning to hold Barr in contempt because
the Justice Department has not provided
the entire Muller report including grand
jury material which would require a
court order DOJ officials told reporters
they continue to engage with committee
staff adding House Democrats impose
quote unreasonable terms on the Attorney
General brett Johnson thank you